that breaking news just coming into us
from greater Manchester police Mason
Greenwood the Manchester United Striker
has had charges of attempted rape and
assault dropped this is uh more than a
year after he was originally arrested
the charges as I said included attempted
rape and assault they have been
discontinued by the crown prosecution
service that's coming from greater
Manchester police Greenwood was due to
stand trial in November this year
accused of attempted rape assault and
coercive control however greater
Manchester police today confirming that
the CPS have dropped all charges against
him so that is Mason green with the
Manchester United Striker dropped or the
child has had all the charges against
him dropped